hi today we're looking at world models
by David ha and Jung schmidhuber this is
a paper that's concerned with
reinforcement learning and especially
with the problem of say you have an
environment that you interact with and
you kind of need to learn to act in it
but it could be for example very
expensive to always query the
environment so let's say you have like a
robot and it needs to do something in
the world and you kind of to have a
robot execute something and then observe
it is quite expensive cost electricity
and so on so you would like to sort of
minimize how many times the how many
times this happens so here searching for
a good picture they're concerned with
problems for example like this this is a
race car simulator simulator there's an
open eye gym environment for that the
other one that they use is so-called
like a doom experiment where as you look
at this there's a couple of monsters and
they're shooting fireballs at you and
the task is just to kind of avoid the
fireballs so the entire point of the
paper is that I don't actually need to
interact with the environment nor to
learn it I can simply kind of learn a
model of the environment and then learn
using that model so basically I can
learn how the environment works and then
simply use my imagination of the
environment my model in order to to
learn from that so I don't have to
interact with the real environment
anymore so how do they do this they do
it in multiple stages here first thing
they do is they collect a bunch of
samples from the environment so they go
to the environment they simply do a
random policy
and then they collect a bunch of samples
I think the process is outlined down
here somewhere
we saw it before here collect ten
thousand roll outs from around the
policy next they train a VA e here to
kind of learn the environment so that's
where that's where that comes in this is
all done in stage it's not end to end
the VI e is simply a model that takes a
takes in this case a video frame here
and it sends it through an encoder
neural network to obtain what's called a
latent representation which is a much
smaller dimensional representation so if
the image is like 64 by 64 pixels then
the the latent code could be as little
as like a hundred or even ten
dimensional so you see that there's
quite a bit of compression going on and
this is a variational auto encoder it's
not really important here that it's
variational since they the difference is
the variation auto encoder is kind of a
stochastic process whereas the regular
auto encoder isn't but they introduced
elasticity later again so it's not
particularly important but so it's a
variational auto encoder which means
they obtain a latent representation that
defines distribution over outputs so
they send this they sample from this
latent distribution that they obtain and
then they feed this to the decoder and
the decoder can give back what it thinks
the encoder encoded so the decoder tries
to reconstruct as close as possible this
original frame that was given to the
encoder but of course it can't because
we've compressed it so much to this to
this lower dimensional representation
here so it kind of does its best effort
so what you hope to achieve with this is
that kind of the decoder learns for exam
well there's always here this is the the
ceiling right here is always gray so
basically you you shouldn't actually
need to encode this in your in your xiv
if it's always gray the decoder should
learn this by itself so your hope is
that the disease alight in
representation will simply end up
containing just the information that's
kind of different or between the between
the individual frames which here I guess
would be kind of the the fireballs
coming and your position relative to
them and that's that's what's changing
if you think about this environment so
your hope is that the latent
representation captures only that
whereas all the static parts that are
irrelevant or never change are kind of
captured by the encoder and the decoder
architecture by itself so yeah it's
important to note that coder and decoder
obviously always the same for all the
frames whereas the Z representation of
course is there is one per frame so each
frame will give you a different Z and
that's yeah so you can imagine how that
works or how that's going to be useful
so they they train this on like a random
randomly collected sample of the
environment until they're confident they
now have a good model of the environment
and then what they do next is they use
this in order to train an RNN so again
they kind of have their their
compression model of the environment
what they do now is they use these these
states you see here here here here that
they get from that and they train how
these latent representations evolve over
time so with an origin here it goes over
time so the RNN will always kind of
predict what's the next stage
of the environment going to be but
importantly maybe compared to
environment models that we've discussed
before in for example imagination
augmented agent paper there we always
try to directly predict the future
pixels so to say of the future frame
here the environment model is over the
latent representation of course this
means that the this is much smaller
space so if you're compression model is
good then this should be much easier to
learn than say like a full end-to-end
environment model so this model learns
how your latent states evolve over time
given your actions right so you can you
can imagine that the Z being an abstract
representation of your state and then
your action and the distal isn't adorned
and the Ireland will predict what's the
next latent representation and there is
a what's called a temperature parameter
to control the stochasticity I've
already told you this this um there is a
stockist his stochasticity built in to
this so the RNA will simply output like
some some vector what it thinks is the
next thing going to be and they don't
use this directly as the next step but
they parameterize a kind of a mixture of
Gaussian distributions coupled with a
decoder here in order to give a random
distribution over there the next state
and they control the amount of
randomness with the temperature
parameter they argue that this comes in
handy later so alright so what do we
have we have a system that can compress
the environment into what we would call
an essential part right every frame we
extract there what's important in that
frame then next we have a model that can
predict given a state and in action
what's the next state going to be the
next
latent state so technically we now have
an environment model right given a state
we can simply give a state and a policy
we can simply use this model to roll
forward so the last component is the
actual policy and the actual policy here
as you can see is in there K simply a
linear model the linear model will take
the Z which is the latent representation
of the current state and the H which is
the current state of the of the RNN that
models the environment over time and it
will it simply is a linear linear
function of the two gives you the action
probabilities or I guess the law gates
of the actions so it's a really really
simple controller over these things and
they do this in order kind of to show
that that the main part of the work is
being done by this environment model and
given the environment model you only
need very few parameters basically to
then learn a policy here is the kind of
what I said in in a diagram so the
observation goes into the the
compression of the VA e the latent
representation of that goes into the RN
together with the hidden state from the
last step and this will out output a new
hidden state which goes here into the
controller and we also directly take
this Z into the controller and then from
these two we perform an action which now
we have a choice it could go to the
environment right give you the next
observation but also or at the same time
since you kind of need to update your or
an n it can go here and update your or
an N because it will need to predict the
next state the thing is we can also now
leave
away this path which means we can simply
take our RNN and our kind of imagine the
next latent representation put it
through the decoder part of the VI e and
use that as an observation I hope this
makes sense it it's it's rather
intuitive right you have a model of the
environment you can simply use this
instead of the real environment so
that's a bit of pseudocode here and they
do a bunch of experiments right so we're
primarily interested so they they say
they see here how okay our compression
works and this is the real frame and
this is the reconstructed frame kind of
looks you know captures the essence of
what's going on and I actually want to
go down here
the visiting experiment so what they
what they do here in the car racing
experiment is they kind of learn this
entire thing right and then they learn a
policy in the in the real world so in
the environment using using this model
up here this procedure where they always
go to the environment and here is the
exact experiment setup so first day were
they collect again robots for a random
policy they train to be a tight rein the
RNN and then they learn the the latent
sorry they learn the controller using
the entire model but in kind of the real
world so they always interact with the
environment but because they also have
their kind of latent representation of
the observation and not directly the
observation they get a higher score and
also the policy that they use in the
real environment transfers to the
environment model so the policy that
learn
in the true environment it transfers to
the imagined so if they use the imagined
model as an environment it also performs
well in the next experiment they're
gonna try to do this the other way
around
they're gonna try to learn only using
their model of the environment and then
see whether or not the policy transfers
to the true environment so that's what
they do here they collect collect again
a sample from the environment they train
the via either trained RNN and then they
simply use this virtual environment what
they call it
in order to learn a policy and at the
end they try to transfer you to learn
policy on the actual environment and
given the results you see yep so they
you see the kind of best it it does I
would say is about here where the actual
score is you can see in this and also in
this setting is higher than the kind of
previous best algorithm in the open era
gene when you go from virtual to actual
so what this means is kind of yeah you
can you can train using this imagined
model and then it will actually transfer
but but there's a crucial thing and that
is this kind of temperature thing here
you can see a lot of times they actually
don't manage to reach a good score if
this parameter is wrong what does this
parameter do this parameter controls as
we discussed the stochasticity of the
model so basically the environment model
doesn't directly imagine
future state but it imagines a
distribution over future states and the
higher this parameter the more
stochastic this distribution is
basically the more uniform I guess the
more entropy you have in these future
states we just result we've seen this
temperature parameter here which is
important because they go into length
explaining why in this entire page here
that we skipped you see just text
they're cheating the world model which
basically they say okay if you have a
wrong model if you have a model that's
wrong on the environment and you train a
policy on it necessarily it's gonna make
probably find like a policy then that's
kind of exploits the wrongness of this
model so you might be able to walk
through walls or fly or ignore the the
fireballs or basically yeah fine find
some or find that if you stand next to a
wall in your imagination you'll never
get hit something like this which isn't
true in the real world and so the the
policy will exploit that and to counter
this they simply basically turn up this
temperature parameter giving them a more
stochastic procedure meaning they
imagine a lot of kind of different
futures and they turn their policy on
all of them or in expectation of a
sample of them which means that if the
environment model is wrong it is kind of
I wanna say if it's wrong this correct
ready it doesn't but if it's wrong you
still sample different futures so if it
has one wrong future you still have the
other ones to kind of punish the policy
if it tries to exploit this one mistake
at least that's the the reasoning behind
it so the that's that's how they do this
you
can interact with their trained
environment models online somehow they
also give a a kind of a look at what
they would like to have his they would
like to kind of instead of collecting
the environment model from random
rollout to take would try to train it
and to use it again to collect more data
to train more environment model than use
the environment better environment model
to train more the policy and so on in a
stepwise fashion book they don't
actually do it they simply describe it
yeah and the rest of the paper is a bit
of related work and discussion it's very
it's very prosaically
written kind of different from what
you're used to if you read a lot of
these papers but yeah I hope you can
know you know what's going on and see
you next time